y para hablar de salud nos acompaña como
todos los días nuestra periodista más
Romero salamar bienvenida bienvenida
Gracias y Comencemos con buenas noticias
porque hay un tratamiento contra la
leucemia que ya parece tener resultados
al menos prometedores Así es vamos a
detallar todo esto y en esta Crónica no
tiene No no es contra cualquier leucemia
Es contra la leucemia mieloide aguda que
es una de las más agresivas que existen
el fármaco se llama reumenip es de la
farmacéutica sindax que es
estadounidense y se toma de forma oral
se publicaron los resultados en fase 1
fases muy iniciales todavía de los
estudios de un total de 60 pacientes 32
tuvieron alguna respuesta positiva eso
es más de la mitad un 53%, pero es que
además 18 de estos 60 pacientes un 30%
tuvieron una remisión completa de su
leucemia Es muy importante tener en
cuenta que estamos hablando de pacientes
que no habían tenido resultados
positivos con ningún otro tratamiento o
que habían vuelto a desarrollar leucemia
después de haber conseguido una curación
y que se consideraban prácticamente
condenados a muerte no que eran personas
que ya estaban viendo hacia los cuidados
paliativos entonces por eso estamos
hablando pues al menos en estos 18 casos
de unos resultados verdaderamente
sorprendentes y verdaderamente
prometedores y usted nos mencionaba que
este medicamento será oral Pero qué se
conoce de cómo funciona este fármaco no
funciona contra todos los casos de
leucemia mieloidea aguda sino contra dos
subtipos genéticos que están presentes
en aproximadamente el 40% de estos casos
exponemos uno de los ejemplos de estos
subtipos genéticos que está en el Gen
kmt2a y lo que le pasa en esta variante
no cuando está los pacientes de leucemia
tienen esto es que se reordena y un
reordenamiento genético que hace que se
creen unas proteínas nocivas que se
adhieren al ADN de las células Y al
hacerlo así a través de la menina que es
una proteína también que está presente
en la superficie del ADN pues se activa
una generación de células cancerígenas
este medicamento lo que hace es
interrumpir este proceso bloquea que
estas proteínas nocivas se puedan juntar
con la menina y se puedan juntar con el
ADN por lo tanto no se generan células
cancerígenas digamos que inhibe la
meninas es el término no que están
utilizando es una realmente este fármaco
es una obra de arte digamos de
ingeniería química y molecular se toma
oralmente como decías este componente
tan chiquito que se adhiere a la menina
y hace que no encajen digamos que no
puedan encajar con las estas proteínas
nocivas increíble los avances de la
ciencia mar y usted también nos
mencionaba que este medicamento apenas
está en la fase inicial de investigación
si bien Todavía es muy temprano Cuáles
son los efectos secundarios que se
conoce lo que sabemos hasta ahora es que
los efectos secundarios fueron
generalizados una amplia mayoría de los
pacientes sintieron algunos de los
efectos adversos del tratamiento pero
ninguno de ellos tuvo que interrumpir el
tratamiento a raíz de estos efectos
adversos los principales Fueron por
ejemplo arritmias de corazón náuseas
también a fiebre todo se tratar o Pues
al menos rebajar contener no con otros
tratamientos Pues por los lados no
ayudando a este tratamiento contra el
cáncer como decías no este estudio está
en fase uno y precisamente la fase 1
También es para ajustar las dosis del
medicamento entonces forma parte de este
proceso no que haya quizás algunas dosis
demasiado altas o que generen más
efectos contrarios También es importante
decir que como parte de esta fase uno se
publicó además en nature un estudio
además no del principal una segunda
parte digamos del estudio del mismo
equipo de investigación donde concluían
que habían encontrado ocasiones en que
esta proteína de la menina había logrado
mutar para desarrollar resistencia al
fármaco como si fuera una bacteria
digamos que desarrollar resistencia a un
antibiótico y para eso trajimos una cita
de Scott Armstrong que es uno de los
autos autores de uno de los varios
autores del estudio que básicamente
decía que el hecho de que estas células
cancerígenas estén pasando por tanto
esfuerzo para combatir el efecto de este
medicamento es una señal no de que la
investigación está dando en el clavo no
que es la primera vez que un fármaco
ejerce una grado tal depresión contra el
cáncer que no puede ser más que un
indicador de que están en buen camino
bueno y con este buen camino de este
medicamento mar cuál podría ser el
impacto en la lucha mundial contra la
leucemia claro Tenemos que tener en
cuenta no que esta leucemia mieloide
aguda es el cáncer de sangre más
frecuente en los adultos y que tiene
unas cifras verdaderamente dolorosas la
media de supervivencia de este tipo de
cáncer es de 8 meses y medio la tasa de
supervivencia a dos años vistas del 32%
a 5 años vistas del 24% unas tasas de
supervivencia muy bajas es un cáncer muy
agresivo doloroso para los pacientes
también para todo su entorno familiar y
sus allegados y además muchos de ellos
son mayores de 65 años eso puede ser una
de las cosas uno de los motivos No el
envejecimiento de la población de que
además haya ido aumentando tanto en los
últimos años desde 1990 se han duplicado
prácticamente
tanto los casos como las muertes anuales
estamos ahora en 2017 cifras las más
actuales que hemos encontrado en 120.000
diagnósticos anuales 100.000 muertes
anuales que era mucho camino por
recorrer esto puede durar mucho tiempo
hacerse estudios No todavía como con más
gente sobre todo y también queda ver qué
tan accesible será este tipo de
tratamientos contra el cáncer sabemos
que son muy caros Pero bueno al menos
sabemos que una enfermedad tan amplia
que afecta tanto a tantas personas sobre
todo del Norte global pues al menos
empezamos a ver una luz al final del
túnel Y eso es una gran noticia amar
Esperamos que continúe bien y que luego
el medicamento pueda ser accesible para
la mayor parte de la población le
propongo que terminemos con más noticias
positivas en salud y que también tienen
que ver con la leucemia sí tenemos un
bonus tracket para hoy digamos en este
caso relacionado con la leucemia y
también con el VIH porque ayer se dio a
conocer el cuarto caso de la curación de
una infección por el virus de la
inmunodeficiencia humana era un caso que
se conocía se dice público el año pasado
pero ahora digamos que se ha hecho
oficial al publicarse en la revista
científica shell se ha hecho de forma
parecida a los tres casos anteriores
eran pacientes que tenían VIH y leucemia
y que para curar o tratar la leucemia
tuvieron un trasplante de células madre
no en este caso es un poco distinto
porque las células madre venían de un
trasplante de cordón umbilical y no de
un donante adulto de trasplante de
médula ósea qué se hace que las células
madre tienen una variación que está
presente aproximadamente solo en el 1%
de la población que hace resistente al
VIH la persona que las tenga Entonces
digamos que el sistema inmune de las
personas Al recibir el trasplante se
reinicia esta vez con esta variante con
esta diferencia que los hace resistentes
al VIH y logran digamos salir de la
infección por este tipo de virus También
es importante recordar que hoy en día el
VIH digamos no tiene cura no es que esto
sea un camino digamos hacia la cura del
VIH porque el trasplante de médula ósea
es un procedimiento muy difícil es
doloroso y tiene también tasas de
supervivencia bastante bastante bajas
Entonces no se puede puede aplicar a
gran escala pero sí es cierto que da una
cierta esperanza y que también puede dar
pistas hacia el futuro para una un
Enigma todavía que existe hoy en día
como es la cura del VIH y así la ciencia
siga avanzando para combatir las
enfermedades más gracias por toda esta
sección de salud Gracias María Clara